Ted Cruz is now clearly even more disgusting
than we thought.
And we thought Ted Cruz was pretty damn disgusting
after his recent Cancun Cruz fiasco, where
he fled the country amid a power outage in
his state of Texas to go sit on the beach
in Cancun.
Ted Cruz has now been pictured scrolling through
his phone, paying no attention to Senate hearings
yesterday about the January 6th Trump capital
riots.
This is a picture of Ted Cruz, a very, very
busy on his phone as testimony about exactly
what happened on January 6th is taking place.
Ted Cruz completely disrespecting the hearings.
He doesn't care.
And here is video.
You will hear testimony going on and then
you will see the camera cut to Ted Cruz, who
is on his phone.
He's tapping in a way, it almost looks like
he's playing a game, maybe booking a flight
to Cancun or Acapulco.
I don't know exactly what he's doing.
Let's take a look at this.
Based on the intelligence that we received,
we plan for an increased level of violence
at the capital and that some participants
may be armed, but none of the intelligence
we received predicted what actually occurred.
Yeah, I don't know I don't know if he's trying
to book flights somewhere warm, I don't know
if he's playing a game.
I don't know if he's tapping out a text to
that group of friends that were really pleased
with the three hundred and nine dollars a
night rate that they were going to get at
whatever hotel in Cancun they went to last
week.
Ted Cruz just cannot stop embarrassing himself
almost daily at this point in time.
Not the only person, by the way, I don't want
to only focus on Ted Cruz here in our coverage
of these hearings yesterday.
Not the only person disrespecting these hearings
into the Trump riots, radical Republican Senator
Ron Johnson.
Again, Ron Johnson, just one of the worst.
He took his question and answer period and
used it to float some ridiculous conspiracy
theory about how the January 6th riots were
actually done by everybody other than Trump
supporters, people pretending to be Trump
supporters, left wingers, whatever, but they
weren't really Trump supporters.
Take a look at this.
This is a people I pastor who passed me along
Constitution Avenue.
Some are indignant and contemptuous of Congress,
but not one appeared angry or incited to riot.
Many of the marchers were families with small
children.
Many were elderly, overweight or just plain
tired or frail traits not typically attributed
to the riot prone.
Many were propolis shirts or carried propolis
black and blue flags.
Although the crowd represented a broad cross-section
of Americans, mostly working class by their
appearance and manner of speech, some people
stood out.
A very few didn't share the jovial, friendly,
earnest demeanor of the great majority.
Some obviously didn't fit in.
And he describes four different types of people
plainclothes militants, agents, provocateurs,
fake Trump protesters and then disciplined
uniformed column of attackers.
I think these are the people that probably
planned this.
He goes on, The D.C.
Metropolitan Police were their usual professionally
detached selves, standing on curbs or at street
crossings and exchanging occasional greeting
for marchers.
When we crossed First Street Northwest to
enter the Capitol grounds where the Capitol
Police had jurisdiction, I noticed no police
at all.
Several marchers expressed surprise.
The openness seemed like a courtesy gesture
from Congress, which controls security.
They weren't actual Trump supporters.
They were provocateurs.
They were fake Trump protesters.
And this is very similar to that.
It was actually antifa in disguise antifa
with Trump shirts and Trump flags and Trump
hats and some of them armed.
And they even played they they really acted
all day going to the Trump rally and cheering.
It was all an act.
That's what we are led to believe, believe.
And I don't even know how much more we have
to talk about this.
It's horrifying and delusional that we still
have members of the Senate floating this idea.
But the January 6th Trump riots were really,
really simple.
It wasn't antifa.
It wasn't mostly a Muslim crowd.
It wasn't mostly a Mexican crowd.
It wasn't the LGBT community.
It wasn't socialist's.
It wasn't Biden supporters or Obama supporters
or Bernie Sanders supporters.
It wasn't Black Lives Matter.
It was Trump supporters who mostly are white,
Christian and male.
Now, there are some exceptions, OK?
It wasn't most white people.
Most white people weren't Trump rioters.
It wasn't most men.
Most men wanted nothing to do with the riots.
It wasn't most Christians.
But those who were there were disproportionately
men, white and Christian.
But most importantly, they were Trump supporters.
That's it.
No more conspiracy theories, hypotheses or
wild speculations are needed to determine
who it was that was there on that day.
But Ron Johnson doesn't care and he's going
to keep it going.
And we'll have more coverage from yesterday's
Senate hearings about the Trump riots on our
Instagram page.
You can follow us on Instagram at David Pakman,
The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman dot com.